it says a particle mass 10 kilograms
uh falls from rest should have mentioned
that
falls from rest that will become
significant later
it falls from rest and is subject to a
force of 98 minus 2v
newtons where v is the speed at time
t seconds so that's that's a function
but you expected that already
okay so we're looking for these three
things momentum
and this is one of the reasons why i
pulled it out because we don't tend to
think about
momentum all that much we are thinking a
lot about forces and we forget
this thing called momentum so you need
to remember it terminal velocity we know
how to get that we'll show it
in a second and then a total distance
that's traveled let's have a go
how do we begin how do most of these
kinds of
resistive motion questions begin you
start with a force right
so here's where you start right now f
equals m a so you know what the
left-hand side is going to be
that's 98 minus 2b
okay and you also know what the mass is
so that's
10. now
we're going towards momentum momentum
so how do we get to momentum what's the
closest idea to momentum
it's velocity right what's the
difference between
velocity and momentum mass good
so just like force is acceleration with
mass
momentum is velocity of mass remember
this okay so mv
so therefore if i'm heading towards
velocity then how should i write
acceleration
dv dt right
i'm going that way because i'm gonna
have to do things with times later on
okay and i want momentum as a function
of time
okay so far so good i'll divide through
rearrange
98 minus 2v i'll divide both sides by
10.
that gives me 49 minus v on 5.
you happy with that i just divided by
yeah okay now
where's the what's the problem here um i
need to integrate with respect to
v but this is not with respect to v so
that's why i take the reciprocal
okay so so far so good
okay so now you integrate you integrate
you get t
on this side and what do you get on the
right hand side v on the bottom
so you get there's an extra factor of
five
right the inside function the reverse
chain rule is negative one
negative and then you get your log right
like so plus it's a constant
good because it's indefinite right so
you've got to find your constant
it's not trivial to find the constant
because you have this log function in
there
so you have to say from rest right
when excuse me t equals 0 v
equals 0 because it's from rest so you
punch that all the way in you get 0
equals
minus 55 log 49
right there's v 0 plus my constant so
there's my constant
okay watch out it's so easy to say oh
initial conditions
sorry initial conditions were zero so i
don't have to worry about the constant
no you absolutely need to worry about
the constant
not trivial okay now we can pop that in
so here's our velocity equation oh sorry
our time equation
is equal to i'll put the positive part
first
okay so i'm getting there slowly making
progress
i need to get to a velocity equation so
i don't want time as a subject what
should i do
i should combine the logs right
i think that's what that hand gesture
meant okay so
49 over i'm hoping well that's what the
jet hand just means
um i've got 49 over 49 minus v
yes thumbs up that's equal to time
okay i will divide by 5
so that i just have the log over there
now what
rephrase it rephrase it exponential
equation
e to the i'll write that as point 2 t so
i don't have to worry about the fraction
equals this
i want v is the subject right so this is
upside down so what should i do
i should take the reciprocals of both
sides so i'll put this over here
so that's my reciprocal right there so
far so good okay i'm almost there
49-3
yep and then i just have to do a bit of
flipping around
i think you end up with this
yep yeah you happy with that i did two
things didn't i
i subtracted 49 and then i reversed the
order because i multiplied by minus one
i think we've done we do this so many
times you can kind of get used to it all
right now this is not a momentum
equation
it's a velocity equation yes
the witch s
yes
what mg
is there any gravity you play it doesn't
tell you anything about
up or down
yeah okay all right yeah but this is the
force this is the whole force
right it's subject to a force of that's
it
that's the entirety of the force does
that make sense
was that the is that what you're off by
i added energy
right yeah okay so
if it says subject if this is the force
right
then then that's that's it that's all
there is
to the force okay um this is different
to say oh it's not on there if you have
a look at question three
right um question three is different it
says a toy rocket of mass
you can't see it sorry um it's projected
upwardly from rest
by means of a force right so that means
when that they talk about that force
then that's just an upward propulsion
and gravity hasn't been accounted for
because that's just doing that part
right whereas this when it says
it's subject to a force of that's it
full stop no other forces
i guess you could say that's the
resultant force okay
all right so hold on
we were mid idea
what do i need to change i have to
multiply by mass right because i don't
want
velocity i want momentum
right so almost we don't need we don't
add in mass
we multiply by mass and mass is 10 which
gives you this done
okay very quickly let's go through parts
two and three because they're relatively
simple
i'm looking for a terminal velocity and
this is this is
if you get to this point terminal
velocity is extension one stuff
how do you get a terminal velocity out
of this equation
good right so you're really saying the
limit as t
approaches infinity of the velocity
right
and you can see this is going to be on
the denominator it's going to shrink to
0
so you're going to get 49 times one
minus zero
which is 49 meters per second that's
good
okay part three last one
we need a total distance right in the
first five seconds
so that's from time equals zero to time
equals five so how we're going to do
this
what tool are we going to use i think
you've got a zero and a five you've got
boundaries right so total distance
you just go naught to five right of
velocity with respect to time there you
go
okay now i don't think it's all that
many lines you've already got your
velocity equation here
take that 49 out the front from not to
five of one minus
e to the minus point two t with respect
to time
okay you can help me we can all do this
together right even knowing nothing
about the situation
what happens on nga1 you get t
what happens when i integrate this
plus the double negative five e to the
minus point two t okay you pop in zero
and five it ends up not being trivial
because
the z the five boundary right you're
getting five plus
five e to the one
negative one minus one minus zero
plus five e to the zero which is
five right so you can't you can't not
do either of these signs these will
cancel right
so you're getting 49 times 5
over e over e
yeah which is like 90.13 some some
blah blah blah so you round off